um don't we after I give you a
compliment like that don't try to switch
it and you know maybe one no I'm
knocking I just felt weird so no I
really did but I had a good time with a
lot like I really have it's funny though
we don't we don't really keep in touch
okay
wait is that on a podcast no I'm gonna
tell you have to do with no no lots of
yeah because you know when when I got
onto MADtv the one guy that was the
nicest to me was Will Sasso yeah he took
me in I hung out with him a lot and he
wouldn't you get a mm yeah mm and he
would invite me to his barbecues and we
went out at night and it was really cool
he was the only senior cast member that
made me feel like you know welcome on
the show everyone else was standing down
fish and cold you know and when he left
the show I didn't talk to him for five
years and he would call me and I
wouldn't ever call him back
why it's just a character defect of mine
why it's not because of hate or lust
because I just don't like I don't pick
up anyone like when I have to go on the
road and have to call her mm-hmm it's so
difficult but you talk but I do it
because I love her and I want to connect
and I don't want to lose this mm-hmm so
I just I want to do it you know but it's
like you even you know even when I'm on
the phone I'm just terrible at
connecting in that way but am I now
right yeah I don't I think it's just
sheer laziness that's different than
what you don't care yeah maybe you're
saying maybe Wow yeah yeah how did you
not care about Will Sasso it's not okay
no that's not the right word than that I
think what you're saying it you're
twisting it you know man it's just like
how do you not care about me we
I know I know we had I remember room
service no night in San Francisco we
went to this Italian restaurant oh it
was great
I remember that and I remember these
moments right the first time I saw your
dick can I say that every day do that
now he would take a stick out like put
it in the bread to be like yeah crazy
man yeah yeah but I want to apologize to
you about that yeah I do I it's it's
just a character
but you know this this podcast is about
our flaws exposed our supposed a lot of
flaws yeah and this is great and I'm
willing to say it I am sorry I that is a
flaw of mine it's not because I don't
like you it's not because I have any
kind of resentment or ill-will
it's just that I'm lazy and I'm used
Ivan hermit the only times people see me
out is either I'm eating or I'm at a
club
okay I take that back there we go it's
not that he's lazy
he's a hermit and her has he he has this
thing where he thought that if people
know him too well they won't like him
and he has a fear of letting people in
too deeply to where they might turn him
away
two questions though but you kept in
touch with Rosenbaum I mean no barely I
mean he'll call me like but he works it
three weeks ago he goes I had a guest
that fell out right last minute can you
do I was like I don't know I'm saying
over the years he's more pursuing he
pursues it yeah yeah so that's the thing
is I I see I didn't pursue it either so
I have my own character deep flaws so
like but it's still I know how about you
when I would see you it'd be like we
love ya like pure love see because
there's a lot of like I'll say this I do
have a good connection with you yeah and
um somebody said this about you I'm not
gonna say no I want you to say it I love
it this is great can I yeah I love it
yeah I hope she's okay with it yeah yeah
but like Melissa McQueen because she
opened for me yeah she she absolutely
loves you yeah I love her too she
says Bobby's got one of the softest
hearts in Hollywood yeah and I said I
know that about him
yeah I feel that cuz we talked about a
lot of stuff yeah I know yeah I know a
lot of stuff about you and I think that
you know a lot of about me and I was
like I know I don't talk to him like
she's like yeah and she's like duh she
didn't really get coachmen on it she's
like just hit him up because I was
starting to see you yeah and but she's
like I absolutely love him he's one of
the soft hearts and that's and so it's
back at you I'm gonna see something
negative oh no what I want to say is
this is that in I hate to say this cuz I
love this town I love Hollywood I love
California
you're a real California and I'm it yeah
fake one but I'm NOx I came here I was
18 so I've almost feel like I am cuz I
was 30 years but you're the og could you
born here yeah and the people [ __ ] on la
la people take know la don't want you
get the [ __ ] out I love I liked it yeah
I love our business this is what we
signed up for but I will say I get my
butt hurt I'm getting better at it the
people that they're it's not they don't
change you know this is a I think
Lindsay Lohan said this is a great line
she said success doesn't change you it
magnifies who you already are so when
you get successful you think people
change like going back to their
Bernstein bears it was already there but
it was like hidden for me whatever and
one thing I can say about you from the
moment I met you when you came up to me
at the rib joint in Universal Tony
Roma's the wall and you were like 1995
and I was just starting to hit but you
know like he gave me names Bobby do call
me okay how are you gonna be tonight
yeah yeah the same guy that made me in
the garage Wow yeah dude that's [ __ ]
real [ __ ] I like that Tony Romo's yeah
but that's rare
why not happen they've got to in two
minutes yeah yeah I started sweating my
bad yeah I was seeing earlier so good I
don't take it personally but if it was a
while I thought I don't love Bobby yeah
why don't I talk to him
[Music]